ça fait 20 ans que j'utilise un macbook
pro en ordinateur principal alors j'en
ai vu passer des MacBook Pro et puis
dernièrement les MacBook Pro avec la
puce M1 pro que j'ai à titre perso que
j'utilise à titre perso qui est là qui
est là ça c'est la m2 pro donc
aujourd'hui on va regarder qu'est-ce que
vient apporter ce MacBook Pro avec la
puce m2 pro est-ce qu'il faut aller
dessus si vous avez un pro est-ce que ça
vaut le coup si vous avez un macbook pro
avec un processeur vinted est-ce qu'il
faut venir changer est-ce que ça vaut le
coup de switcher dessus aujourd'hui en
2023 sur le MacBook Pro 16 pouces après
la même question pour le MacBook Pro 14
pouces pour aller sur la nouvelle puce
on va tout regarder quels sont les
nouveautés qu'est-ce que ça vous raconte
et au final on verra cet ordinateur est
intéressant et on va même regarder la
configuration au niveau du prix parce
que les prix c'est toujours très élevé
chez Apple mais vous allez en face une
très jolie machine plein de questions
auxquelles on va répondre dans cette
vidéo donc c'est chouette moi je suis
prêt est-ce que vous vous êtes prêt
allez on y va
le design est quasiment le même le
design est même le même c'est le même
design c'est à dire que entre la version
2021 et la version 2023 va regarder
c'est exactement la même chose on se
parle ici de la version en 16 pouces
bien évidemment 16 pouces le métier même
plus regardez moi ça hop là on va les
mettre vraiment à côté on va les mettre
côte à côte on va regarder on a
exactement la même chose les mêmes
connectiques c'est à dire que hop là
vous avez de la recharge en maxify ici
vous avez deux prises en USB C c'est du
thunderbol 4 que vous avez là vous avez
la prise jack exactement la même chose
hop là on switch de l'autre côté du HDMI
et sur votre MacBook Pro avec la puce m2
Pro peut venir brancher le moniteur 8k
c'est très très cool vous avez encore de
l'usb-c sont dans bol 4 comme ça il y en
a un peu de tous les côtés et vous avez
un lecteur de carte SD pour venir
brancher votre carte alors moi ça c'est
cool le temps de carte SD je l'aime bien
j'ai une petite mésaventure parce que il
a fonctionné au début puis très
rapidement il s'est mis à plus
fonctionner donc j'utilise un lecteur de
carte externe ça c'est un peu un peu
relou et ça c'est quand même un peu
voilà ça fait un peu ça fait un peu yes
mais bon il y a des garanties derrière
c'est que moi j'ai strictement rien fait
je suis resté comme ça vous voyez c'est
exactement le même design donc il y a
vraiment pas de changement à l'extérieur
et lorsque vous venez vous ouvrez alors
je les inversé là c'est à dire que mon
macbook pro M1 pro et là ça c'est le M2
pro et si vous les ouvrez bien vous
allez voir c'est exactement la même
chose à l'intérieur aussi vous avez
cette énorme trackpad qui se situe juste
ici vous avez ce très grand clavier le
même design avec les haut-parleurs ici
bref c'est la même chose on a les mêmes
écran Super techno très bien maîtrisé et
une fois de plus la différence va se
faire à l'intérieur alors moi je vais
vous dire pourquoi c'est à titre perso
j'utilise justement un macbook pro c'est
vraiment la question qu'on vient se
poser bon bon monsieur gros tu es bien
mignon tes pieds causé par Apple donc
thème Apple tu parles que d'Apple oui et
non surtout non pourquoi parce que
qu'est-ce que je vais venir aimer ici
dans cette marque je vous le dis je m'en
fous en fait je m'intéresse à toutes les
marques il y en a qui sont très bonnes
d'autres moins bonnes actions dans
certains produits naturels bref ce qui
m'intéresse moi ici chez Apple et là où
on voit qu'il y a plein d'autres marques
qui arrivent et qui se développent
vachement bien c'est toute la question
de l'écosystème et ça les marques ont
vraiment compris elles ont mis du temps
à venir apple l'a compris il y a très
longtemps et les autres marroyés elles
ont développé petit à petit en fait le
smartphone c'est le centre de votre
écosystème c'est lui qui va venir tout
piloter on commence avec le smartphone
et Apple a compris très rapidement qu'il
fallait venir faire des ponts entre ces
différents produits air drop est arrivé
et on peut facilement transférer des
fichiers depuis son iPhone vers son mac
vers son iPad c'est très très simple et
c'est tout l'intérêt et les autres
marques le font aujourd'hui est de plus
en plus je vais penser ça me saoule qui
va le faire en a le coup de chair enfin
bref il y a plein de solutions qui
existent aujourd'hui on peut lier son
smartphone sous un PC directement il y a
Windows ça existe pour les smartphones
Android donc la solution elle se
développe énormément donc cette solution
elle est pas propre à Apple ils ont leur
propre technologie mais on la retrouve
un petit peu ailleurs maintenant un truc
qui est aussi très intéressant avec
Apple c'est que comme on est sur un OS
propriétaire et bien c'est totalement
optimisé alors que ces différents sur
Android parce que on va voir différentes
surcouches Android avoir différentes
expériences Windows ça restera toujours
Windows mais pour autant il peut y avoir
des petites variations tandis que là
chez Apple tout est sur maîtrisé c'est
iOS c'est MacOS c'est ipados c'est
watchos tout est super bien maîtrisé
c'est vraiment la force d'Apple et c'est
ça que je trouvais un cran au-dessus des
autres parce qu'il maîtrise tout le
matériel tout le logiciel est encore
avant ils avaient des puces Intel et qui
fonctionnait bien aujourd'hui c'est les
puces maison donc tout est vachement
bien aligné c'est ça qui est chouette et
c'est là où est vraiment la puissance et
la performance donc ça c'est un truc
déjà qui qui m'intéresse et je trouve
vraiment très très bon ici mais au-delà
de ça il y a très bonne chose sur
Android mais en pourquoi est-ce que moi
j'utilise et bien tout le temps un
MacBook Pro tout simplement parce que je
suis créateur de contenu je pense que ça
vous aura pas échappé et parce que il y
a un petit logiciel que j'utilise
lorsque je viens travailler qui
s'appelle Final Cut Pro j'ai appris à
monter sur final cut pro je suis un
utilisateur de Final Cut Pro et même si
aujourd'hui j'ai délégué mes montages et
c'est plus moi qui l'ai fait et bien
j'en fais quand même de temps en temps
j'en fais sur des shorts sur pas mal de
petits trucs et aujourd'hui la maîtrise
pour moi elle se fait sur final que le
pro donc c'est la raison pour laquelle
je reste dans cet écosystème parce que
je suis habitué à travailler sur final
cut pro mais je veux m'ouvrir sur
première pour pas me fermer les horizons
voilà pourquoi aujourd'hui je suis là
dessus il y a final cut pro et puis il y
a une deuxième solution qui m'intéresse
beaucoup c'est Logic Pro parce que je
fais aussi de la musique et que même si
je vous en parle pas et bien j'utilise
Logic Pro que je trouve qu'il y a un
super logiciel et qui permet
effectivement de faire plein plein de
trucs avec plein de plugins bref c'est
puissant c'est simple c'est bien adapté
et c'est très très cool donc tout
l'intérêt effectivement pour moi d'avoir
un MacBook Pro donc voilà je vous ai
fait un petit peu ce laius qui est un
peu long j'en suis désolé mais comme ça
vous comprenez réellement pourquoi parce
que j'utilise un macbook pro au
quotidien alors le MacBook Pro il est
très cool mais il est vraiment pas fait
pour tout le monde et apple l'a reconnu
c'est à dire que si votre truc à vous
c'est la productivité c'est que moi vous
êtes créateur de contenu si comme moi
vous allez utiliser quasiment tous les
jours Lightroom Photoshop votre Final
Cut Pro de temps en temps Lodgy qui et
puis j'utilise très souvent aussi alors
bon Word Excel vous pouvez retrouver
partout et bien c'est une machine qui
est géniale pourquoi parce qu'elle est
très bonne en productivité alors pareil
j'utilise pas lorsque je fais des envois
FTP il y a pas mal de petits outils
j'utilise Roland Claude manager qui est
sur le côté là et j'utilise également
Spotify alors Spotify c'est très malin
très intelligent pourquoi parce que je
crois que dans tous les ordis que j'ai
testé notamment au niveau des PC et bien
le MacBook Pro et celui qui a le
meilleur son et de très loin je testais
des tonnes d'ordi chez Huawei chez Asus
ils sont super très très belle machine
mais la qualité audio et la
spatialisation que vous avez avec un
MacBook Pro vous la retrouvez nulle part
ailleurs c'est démentiel ça vous immerge
vous êtes vraiment dedans et le son
vient de tous les côtés moi je me suis
surpris quand je l'ai entendu j'ai
tourné la tête parce que j'avais du son
qui faisait de côté je dis ouais la
vache super fort là dedans donc ça vous
l'avez effectivement sur la version M1
Pro vous l'avez déjà sur l'Intel avant
donc ça c'est un truc qui marchait déjà
très très bien et où Apple est
extrêmement fort donc si vous êtes
vraiment comme moi sur la productivité
c'est une machine incroyable si par
contre vous êtes gamer et que vous
voulez un grand catalogue de jeu et que
vous voulez un truc qui est vraiment
adapté au top pour le jeu très
clairement n'allez pas sur un MacBook
Pro n'allez pas chez Apple c'est pas ici
que vous aurez ce qui sera le mieux pour
le gaming si vous voulez être vraiment
sur des machines orientées adaptées à
100% gaming vous allez sur un PC c'est
clair par contre si vous voulez que la
productivité tout comme moi que vous
voulez un truc simple fonctionnel qui
marche bien les MacBook Pro sont juste
extraordinaires et c'est la raison pour
laquelle j'utilise beaucoup beaucoup ces
MacBook Pro alors quelle différence on
va avoir effectivement entre le M1 pro
et le M2 pro la dalle c'est la même
chose on va voir la même qualité d'écran
la qualité audio ça va être la même
chose après vous avez le choix entre
différentes configurations on l'avait
déjà vu avec la M1 pro il y a la M1 pro
et la m1x c'est pareil vous avez la m2
pro la m2 max alors je vous ai fait un
petit papier je vais pas vous le
réécrire mais en fait ce qu'il faut bien
comprendre c'est moi j'ai la M1 pro
depuis longtemps j'ai aucun intérêt à
aller sur la mmax parce que c'est pas
dans mes besoins à moi alors peut-être
que dans vos besoins d'avoir dit le moi
dans les commentaires est-ce que vous
sentez que une machine avec que la M1
pro la m2 Pro vous êtes un peu limité
vous avez besoin d'aller beaucoup plus
loin parce que la différence je vais
vous prendre juste la l'exemple sur la
m2 pro c'est à dire que si vous regardez
au niveau des transistors sur la m2 Pro
vous avez 40 milliards transistors vous
arrivez à 67 milliards de transistors
sur la m2 max au niveau du CPU jusqu'à
12 que au maximum sur les versions Pro
sur la version max vous êtes sur le 12
cœurs quoi qu'il arrive et si vous avez
du côté du GPU donc pour écouter
graphique vous montez jusqu'à 19h au
niveau de la version Pro et jusqu'à 38
heures au niveau de la version max donc
il faut vraiment que vous ayez des gros
besoins graphiques mais clairement je
suis pas convaincu vous en ayez
réellement besoin et si vous regardez
également de la mémoire et bien sur la
version m2 Pro vous êtes soit sur 16 Go
niveau de la mémoire soit 32 Go tandis
que sur la version max c'est pareil
c'est de la brutalité vous êtes sur du
32 minimum 64 96 et c'est pareil
également au niveau de tout ce qui va
être intelligence artificielle et bien
vous avez plus loin au niveau des
versions max que la version Pro mais
très honnêtement comme il est là en
version pro c'est une de machine
qui est extrêmement performante vous
n'avez pas besoin d'aller sur la version
max sauf si vous avez des besoins très
définis très précis que vous allez
vraiment manquer de performance sur la
version Pro mais pour mettre la version
Pro à genoux il en faut il faut s'amuser
donc bon moi personnellement la version
Pro me suffit largement j'ai pas besoin
d'aller sur autre chose autre truc il
faut vraiment venir savoir ici mais vous
l'aviez déjà avec la version qu'on avait
avant avec la M13 vous avez également
avec la m2 pro vous avez une dalle qui
est absolument incroyable allez je vais
vous ouvrir la version avec le M2 pro
l'écran est magnifique tellement bien
calibré les couleurs sont Dingo Dingo
Dingo alors vous en rencontre d'une
caméra posée comme ça sur un bureau
c'est un peu complexe mais c'est ouf
c'est ouf ici pour travailler regarder
du contenu faire la retouche photo vous
avez un truc qui est fou complet et ça
c'est vraiment génial en plus de ça
c'est extrêmement fluide vous montez
jusqu'à 120 Hertz et ça c'est
franchement très très bien également
donc là vous avez vraiment quelque chose
qui est juste au top du top vous êtes
sur une dalle mini LED qui est super
bien maîtrisé bref je ne peux que vanter
les mérites de cet écran qu'on va
retrouver sur le MacBook Pro une fois de
plus sur la version N2 pro mais
également sur la version M1 pro qui
était top déjà alors maintenant qu'ils
sont un peu relou et un peu moins bien
moi ce que j'aime un peu moins c'est
cette espèce de grosse encoche ils ont
vraiment voulu unifier les gammes avec
ce qu'on avait sur les iPhone à nous
mettre effectivement une grosse encoche
donc bon on se dit ok une belle encoche
pourquoi pas ça prend le design mais
clairement ça n'a aucun intérêt ici
parce qu'en fait vous n'avez pas face ID
ça aurait été intéressant si vous aviez
même système que dans un iPhone avec fac
ID vous prenez votre iPhone vous le
mettez face à vous tac tac tac il se
déverrouille vous êtes content voilà
sauf qu'aujourd'hui ils ont lancé quoi
dynamic Island et dynamic Island
pourquoi est-ce qu'ils sont pas venus
l'intégrer ici nous faire une petite
bulle plus discrète avec effectivement
des fonctionnalités vous écoutez un
Spotify par exemple et bien PAF vous
pourriez retrouver votre Spotify ici sur
votre Mac je pense que d'un point de vue
purement soft ça aurait été intéressant
et ça aujourd'hui on l'a pas je trouve
ça vraiment con et de toute façon ils
vont pas nous l'annoncer à la dabadou
d'abaludicieux du mois de juin le matin
de dynamique Island ici parce que en
fait vous n'avez pas de bout d'écran
donc il faudrait ressortir une nouvelle
machine alors à moins qu'ils annoncent
en même temps un nouveau MacBook
peut-être un macbook air avec un deck de
Michael Land et qu'après ils mettent à
jour les gammes mais aujourd'hui ça sert
à rien que c'est con d'avoir ça parce
que vous voyez lorsque je viens emmener
ma souris et ben ma souris elle passe
vraiment dessous elle se cache en fait
et je perds un bout de mon écran alors
que si j'avais un truc avec dynamic
Island ça aurait un sens donc ça
aujourd'hui c'est le truc qui est un peu
con quoi et une fois de plus j'ai pas
fait ça à dire j'aurais fait que ça dit
je le comprendrais je l'ai pas je
comprends pas on peut mettre une petite
webcam ça suffira ça viendra un bouffer
un peu moins de contenu donc voyez il y
a encore un truc à venir chercher ici à
faire évoluer alors l'amélioration qu'on
a eu mais c'est pas nouveau on l'avait
déjà avant c'est qu'on est une caméra
ici on full HD la qualité et pas des
gueux si on veut bien faire des appels
en FaceTime c'est très bien la qualité
est bonne ça marche bien là-dessus j'ai
rien à redire c'est correct autre truc
qui est très correct et je vous le
montrer tout à l'heure d'un point de vue
logiciel et bien c'est MacOS alors c'est
pas le sujet je vais pas vous
redévelopper ma coé ici mais Mac OS
c'est une expérience qui est juste
magnifique sur lequel vous allez pouvoir
faire plein de choses une fois de plus
vous prenez un iPad vous le mettez à
côté tac tac c'est une extension de
l'écran vous prenez vous glissez vous
copiez vous déplacez faites ce que vous
voulez c'est très bien très fluide ça
marche bien il y a plein de mises à jour
il y a plein de nouvelles
fonctionnalités c'est vraiment un truc
que j'ai recommandé que j'aime beaucoup
ici une fois de plus et l'autre truc qui
est vachement intéressant au niveau des
Mac et une fois de plus sur le M1 pro et
sur le M2 pro c'est la même chose c'est
que vous avez beau avoir deux
ventilateurs là-dessous vous avez pas du
tout une machine qui va faire du bruit
allez extrêmement silencieuse vous
pouvez venir lui remettre un peu dans la
gueule vous rentrez dedans vous ouvrez
différentes applications vous la faites
vraiment bosser et bien ça va pas
broncher vous allez pas avoir de
problème de chauffe donc ça c'est déjà
très très bien donc vous avez pas votre
oreille qu'un ordinateur qui va être
bouillant vous allez vous dire mon Dieu
que ça crame j'en peux plus c'est
vraiment pas le cas ici en plus de ça
une fois de plus très silencieux et vous
allez pas avoir d'altération de
performance lorsque vous le branché du
secteur et qui va tourner sur batterie
donc ça c'est aussi un point qui est
extrêmement important ça ça arrive
souvent on l'a déjà vu sur PC lorsque
vous le branchez sur le secteur c'est
une machine de course il va venir
chauffer il va ventir vous l'entendez il
vous accompagner vous avez pas tous ceux
dans la pièce bon ok pourquoi pas même
si c'est pas franchement terrible ici
vous allez venir débrancher vous aurez
pas de problème alors après il y a un
autre truc qui est intéressant c'est que
Apple nous annonce qu'on va aller un peu
plus loin avec ce m2 pro par rapport au
M1 pro d'avant au niveau de la batterie
une plus grosse autonomie alors on va
aller un peu plus loin mais une fois de
plus ça va dépendre des usages ça va
dépendre de vous moi je sais que
j'utilise très facilement une journée
une bonne journée voir des fois un petit
peu plus et après faut venir le
recharger le truc qui est intéressant
c'est que si vous avez de la recharge
très très rapide vous avez des blocs de
charge 140 watts qu'on avait déjà avant
alors je sais pas si vous allez voir le
140 watts parce que c'est quand même
très discret c'est écrit ici en fait 140
watts USB C et le 140 toi tu vous
permets de recharger votre Mac très très
rapidement c'est cool et effectivement
ce qui est aussi vachement bien c'est
que depuis le MacBook Pro de 2021 et
bien ils ont remis ça et ça c'est cool
parce que au moins si vous tirez ça à
hache c'est simple ça s'allume pas c'est
aimanté j'adore ce petit système je
trouve pratique claire simplisible ça me
plaît donc autonomie est bonne pas de
chauffe ça surcharge rapidement voilà
c'est une fois de plus un atout
extrêmement important au niveau de ce
mac il y a un autre avantage qui est
arrivé une évolution de 2021 par rapport
à 2023 il en faut forcément et bien ça
va être l'arrivée du wifi 6e donc on va
aller un peu plus loin en termes de
connectivité alors vous en ai déjà parlé
le wi-fi 7 commence à arriver mais pas
aujourd'hui dans les ordis donc ça
arrivera normalement à l'horizon 2024
donc je pense que ce sont des MacBook
Pro en 2025 on aura du wifi 7 à
l'intérieur mais c'est pas pour tout de
suite tout de suite mais pour l'instant
le wifi 6e est bien donc en fait ce
qu'on voit ici très clairement c'est que
ce m2 max il y a moins de grosses
claquas dans la tête entre Intel et la
puce M1 pro qu'on aille retrouver à ma
proie même max là il y a eu un énorme
différence on s'est vraiment dit ok bon
bah là ils seront giflés ça fait mal il
y a une différence qui va être moins
entre la m2 pro que la M1 pro mais si
vous voulez un nouvel ordinateur d'Apple
et bien il faut venir se poser la
question alors on va regarder les trois
grosses différences qui sont réellement
importantes si vous avez un MacBook Pro
un peu vieillissant sur Intel et que
vous vous avez vraiment besoin de
performance par exemple vous avez un
macbook pro de 2019 j'en ai eu un mois
sur Intel c'était une œuvre que j'avais
je crois j'ai pas envie de bêtises et
que vous vous dites bon ok aujourd'hui
je sens que ça commence à ramer les
programmes mettent un peu de temps à
s'ouvrir changer allez-y clairement ça
vaut vraiment le coup parce qu'il y a
une énorme différence alors pour autant
est-ce que ça vaut le coup d'aller sur
la M1 pro si vous en trouvez une un peu
moins cher que la m2 pro pourquoi pas
parce que ça reste une super machine qui
va très bien et qui conviendra
parfaitement bien si maintenant vous
trouvez pas de Hama pro qui vous
intéresse et puis que la m2 Pro vous
fait de l'oeil allez-y parce que elle
est vraiment top top top elle va un peu
plus loin il y a de belles mises à jour
mais il y a pas une énorme différence
entre la M1 pro et la m2 pro ça évolue
ça va plus loin c'est une très jolie
mise à jour si maintenant vous avez un
MacBook Pro 16 pouces ou 14 pouces et
que vous êtes sur un M1 pro pour moi il
n'y a pas d'intérêt à aller sur la m2
pro conservez votre M1 pro en a eu
beaucoup plus loin et puis voyez plus
tard pour le revendre d'occasion parce
qu'il y a toujours une très belle valeur
résiduelle c'est des machines qu'on peut
garder peut-être une petite dizaine
d'années c'est à peu près ce qu'on peut
faire avec un acte donc pas de souci
là-dessus donc ça sert à rien maintenant
troisième cas de figure vous avez un PC
vous voulez de bon allez l'écosystème
max ça me plaît bien je suis pas GAM
pour autant j'ai pas besoin d'un PC
parce que je joue pas des masses et puis
bon Mac OS c'est quand même cool
l'écosystème est top et bien ça vaut le
coup d'aller dessus très clairement
alors une fois de plus elle m'a pro m2
pro max aussi pourquoi pas avoir donc ça
dépend une fois de plus de vous ça
dépend de votre cas de figure mais pour
moi s'il y a un truc à retenir ici c'est
que M1 pro m2 pro de super machine qui
reste toutes les deux très actuelles si
vous me trouvez un impro en
reconditionné moins cher que la m2 Pro 9
allez-y si maintenant vous vous dites je
vais acheter une nouvelle machine je
vous la nouvelle puce et je vais le
garder dans le temps et je vais investir
et je peux le faire la m2 pro sans aucun
problème peut-être la m2 max mais si
vous avez vraiment des gros besoins de
calcul et surtout graphique vous fait du
rendu 3D qui vous faut beaucoup de
puissance de calcul ok vous allez sur la
max je pense que ça conviendra mais si
comme moi vous êtes créateur de contenu
et que vous faites des montages vidéo
vous faites de la retouche photo vous
faites de l'édition photo que vous
faites du traitement de texte ça ça
demande absolument quasiment pas de
ressources bon ça sert à rien d'aller
sur le max vous faites plus il faut
venir économiser un peu parce que et
alors regardez c'est là où on se marre
on va regarder les tarifs parce qu'une
fois de plus c'est très très cherché
Apple alors pour autant j'adore ces
machines pour autant je les trouve
beaucoup trop cher alors regardez on va
chez Apple on va sur les Mac et on va
sur les MacBook Pro et là vous allez
voir c'est vrai qu'on commence un petit
peu à se marrer parce qu'on voit que là
on se parle de plus m2 sur un MacBook
Pro 13 pouces pourquoi pas c'est
peut-être un truc très intéressant aussi
parce que ça marche vraiment bien et si
vous voulez le pro du pro du produit pro
en 14 et 16 pouces vous avez la puce m2
pro m2 max pour regarder tout à l'heure
et on commence à partir de 200399 €
c'est quand même de budget mais
ça reste super machine alors moi je vais
m'intéresser à la version 16 pouces
parce que c'est celle dont je vous parle
mais si vous regardez 14 pouces vous
voyez qu'on commence 2399 et si on veut
sur la puce max on est à 3700 €. bon on
va regarder la 16 pouces moi la confite
que j'ai ici là sur celui-là parce que
celui-là c'est le M1 pro ce que j'ai ici
c'est du 32 Go et j'ai une version avec
deux terrains de stockage donc là je
vois qu'en fait il me propose alors j'ai
les mêmes couleurs c'est gris sidéral et
c'est l'argent qu'on s'en fiche de la
couleur ça change pas du tout le prix là
j'ai une différence à 3000 et là à 3003
en fait la différence que je vais avoir
c'est au niveau de mon stockage voyez je
vais monter sur le 1 Tera je vous
recommande si vous êtes créateur de
contenu de passer sur un terrain j'ai
peur que le 512 soit assez que vous
galériez très rapidement en terme de
stockage s'il faut le mettre dans un
disque dur externe ici et ça j'ai
vraiment je vous le recommande pas moi
j'ai dû interra j'ai souvent plusieurs
projets vidéo qui sont dans mon ordi et
j'ai besoin au bout d'un moment de
décharger quand je suis nettoyage et
tout dedans enfin bref pas s'emmerder
partez sur un terrain ça va vous coûter
un peu plus mais quand on est dans cette
gamme de prix là franchement il faut y
aller donc pour moi on va sur cette
machine là dès le départ vous le voyez
que si vous voulez monter effectivement
après sur le max on attaque directement
le tarif à 4149 €. bon restons sur le
pro une fois de plus est-ce que moi vous
recommander donc on part ici et on va
essayer de regarder un petit peu par
rapport à ce que j'ai en terme
d'équivalence alors à vous de voir une
fois de plus vous restez à 12 cœurs à
quoi qu'il se passe au niveau du CPU
mais si vous voulez monter à 30 cœurs
GPU versus 19 il aura 38 heures vous
voyez on vient rajouter un petit peu ça
vient de taquiner davantage le Nora
Legend dans tous les cas ouais ça c'est
ce cas ici bon on veut se dire que allez
on passe sur la config intermédiaire
plus de 130 au niveau de la mémoire moi
j'ai un 32 Go ça me suffit largement le
75 si vous faites de la vidéo comme moi
je suis pas forcément convaincu
peut-être si on veut se projeter à
l'avenir l'oiseau pour avoir besoin de
plus en plus de ressources et qu'à un
moment va bien monter en 8k il faudra
peut-être booster un peu plus donc
est-ce que ça vaut le coup tout de suite
d'investir davantage en regardant ce qui
va se passer dans 5 ans c'est vraiment
la question que je vous recommande parce
que autant la durée de vie d'un
smartphone c'est 3 4 ans aujourd'hui on
leur nouvelle tous les trois ans ça a
baissé un petit peu donc on est vraiment
là dessus autant en ordi on va le garder
5 6 7 10 qu'il tiendra donc ça vaut le
coup des fois de mettre un peu plus à
l'achat mais pour une machine qui va
pouvoir durer sur vos usages un peu plus
lointain donc il faut vraiment essayer
de se projeter là-dessus on va regarder
sur le 32 que j'ai tout de suite et puis
on va regarder le stockage un terrain
pour moi ça convient voyons déjà sur une
config à
3919 €, si je veux passer sur le 2 Tera
pour être un peu plus confortable et
bien je passe à 4379 c'est tout de suite
beaucoup plus cher je ne suis pas
convaincu que vous ayez besoin de 4
Terra ou de 8 Tera donc bon je vois pas
l'intérêt 8 erreurs vous rajoutez 2000
balles vous passez à 6000 balles pour
moi on y va pas après j'ai toujours les
options chez Apple pour avoir des soft
préinstaller Final Cut Pro Logic Pro
alors le truc qui est intéressant ici si
vous me prenez notamment un Logic Pro
c'est que c'est la licence que vous avez
à vie vous savez ce que si vous me
prenez un autre logiciel musical et bien
sont des abonnements en moi donc ça vous
coûtera plus cher donc ça c'est
intéressant effectivement je suis Apple
et c'est pareil sur le Final Cut Pro ça
vaut le coup d'acheter de la licence une
fois et de la conservé donc voilà un peu
là dessus alors après si vous voulez
vous partez à vous demander j'ai besoin
vraiment de scan mieux de Max de
puissance je veux la puce m2 max et bien
vous allez voir que rapidement ça vient
piquer au niveau du tarif donc j'ai ma
m2 max là ce que je vous disais et là je
peux venir monter un petit peu alors je
suis sur le 32 le cas si vous comptez
sur 64 déjà ça ça pique un petit peu
plus le 2 Tera voyez je suis à 5000
balles et si vous partez après sur le
truc le plus fou fou vous montez à 7599
euros cette config n'est je suis sûr
quasiment pas faite pour vous elle va
être fait pour des usages très
particuliers donc vous n'avez
probablement pas besoin donc bon ça
coûte ça ça coûte très cher en fait
aujourd'hui ce qu'il faut venir retenir
c'est que si vous voulez un macbook pro
avec la m2 pro qui conviendra largement
la config que je vous recommande de
faire ça peut être ça tac tac sur le 62
et vous montez même sur le 1 Tera ça ira
très bien vous êtes un peu moins de 4000
balles c'est très cher ça reste un gros
budget mais vous avez une machine qui
est à toute épreuve voilà donc ce que je
voulais vous dire aujourd'hui ce que je
voulais partager avec vous sur ces
ordinateurs d'Apple alors une fois de
plus je le dis je le dis je le redis
sont des super machines superbe qualité
très bien maîtrisée les mois et bien ça
va effectivement c'est encoche que je
trouve aujourd'hui bon il faut aller un
petit peu plus loin c'est un peu dommage
je suis d'ailleurs quasiment sûr que
c'est la dernière génération qui Apple
nous propose avec cet encoche ici on va
arriver sur du dynamic Island ça très
clairement un sens pour venir nous
l'intégrer différemment ça me paraîtrait
logique sur une machine à 4000 balles
d'abord cette espèce d'encache je vois
plus trop l'intérêt mais au-delà de ça
au-delà de l'encoche moi je l'oublie
totalement lorsque je bosse et pas les
yeux dessus je m'en fous ça me dérange
pas ça reste une excellente machine donc
si vous voulez vraiment de la brutalité
en termes de performance vous voulez une
très belle autonomie une machine qui ne
chauffe pas qui n'est pas bruyante qui
est polyvalente on peut emmener partout
avec soi et bien vous avez ce MacBook
Pro avec le M2 pro m2 max le M1 pro mmax
une fois plus je le recommande je
continue à le recommander allez voir en
reconditionné chez Apple vous avez de
très très jolies choses chez Apple est
également ailleurs alors une fois de
plus petit message attention à votre
conditionneur vérifier que sa
reconditionneur français qui a des vrais
garanties qui va vous assurer d'avoir
des pièces certifiées Apple que vous
êtes peinard ici qui a pas de problème
allez jeter un œil vous allez voir ça
c'est intéressant alors je vous le dis
petit truc en plus c'est pas du tout
sponso mais j'avais été voir Smart avec
qui j'ai fait une Opel saut pour le coup
mais je crois vraiment reconnu seulement
de leur machine sans des machines
pluviales donc vous aurez pas forcément
ça peut-être du M1 pro et quoique mais
au moins vous êtes sûr d'avoir un truc
qui est très très chouette je le glisse
comme ça bon entendeur salut donc voilà
pour ces machines dites-moi vous ce que
vous en pensez je sais pas ce que vous
avez un Mac est-ce que vous posez la
question de switcher de PC hamac lorsque
vous dites les maths je souper j'en veux
plus aujourd'hui je veux un PC marquez
moi ça je suis curieux de voir comment
vous allez arbitrer les choses et puis
une fois de plus si un de ces produits
vous intéresse bien je vous mets les
liens en bas dans la description voilà
on a tout dit on sait tout je vous
embrasse prenez soin de vous et moi je
vais continuer sur mon mac parce que
très très belle machine même si je vois
que ce qu'a proposé Samsung avec ses
machines c'est ouf d'ailleurs on va
tester très bientôt le Galaxy book 3
ultra que j'ai toujours pas j'attends et
je pense que c'est aussi une très jolie
surprise je pense on en parle bientôt je
vous embrasse prenez soin de vous à
bientôt Ciao
[Musique]